hello friends
my name is eric zee i'm the chef owner
of 8x6 taiwanese restaurant
here on st mark's place today i'm going
to show you how i prepare
200 pounds of pork roast i'm going to
show you exactly how we prep it behind
the scenes
and how we use it for a couple of dishes
on the menu time to get to work
we are in the prep kitchen of 886 we
have a
butt load of pork belly here and they
come in slabs like these
there will be small fabrics of hair
to kind of get rid of and the best way
to do it is with
the porch
so the pork belly we get from our
purveyor in chinatown we try to purchase
local as much as possible
supporting small businesses is a very
big deal to us
i bought 200 pounds this will probably
be good for less than a week all this
would
likely serve about 300
pork belly has three sections to me this
is the prime section right here which is
where the spare ribs are that we will
reserve for our stir-fry
looks pretty and has a more balanced
texture and it cooks quicker
and then the sides would kind of be the
trimming where there's a lot of fat
and really really tough muscle that we
have to break down over time
and this into the pork belly sauce is
gonna render it's gonna thicken the
sauce
it's going to emulsify so this is
perfect
another reason why we prep in bulk is
because
you get economy of scale when we buy 200
pounds at a time
it costs us about 2.50 cents per pound
but if you went to whole foods
you get it for like 10 bucks a pound
that's four times more
so as a restaurant you have to save
where you can the whole pork belly gets
used
there's absolutely no waste and we
utilize each part
to its best extent all right we're all
done with 200 pounds and we're gonna
bring these guys upstairs
i got a very big pot of boiling water
and we just gotta throw all the pork
belly in so this step
of blanching solidifies the meat makes
it a lot easier to cut
and also gets rid of some of the
impurities that are in the meat
all right bring on the heat
so we've been cooking for 30 minutes to
change color it's
super solidified we're ready to take it
out
so we got the blanched pork belly there
are nice pieces and the end cuts in here
both
i'm gonna pick out the nice pieces first
those will go into our stir fry so i'm
gonna slice them
put it into this bucket and we'll be
left with the end pieces and i'm going
to take those out
and slice it and that's going to be for
the braids
[Music]
now we'll put all the ingredients in put
the pork in and then it's going to start
braising
soy sauce black sugar
rice wine spice
crispy shallots pork those in
now add in the
because water so thick with all the
gelatin it has to be stirred
every five to ten minutes while it burns
so while the fork is being braised
upstairs what we do
is we have a scale we have the nice
center cut pieces and we have
some bean curd this is going to be our
stir-fry dish and we
portion each one to the exact weight so
that every customer gets the exact
same amount of pork and tofu when an
order comes in we take out one of these
containers and everything is ready to go
restaurant food is designed to be about
60
finished when it's ordered for the sake
of time and time management
you don't want to be sitting at a
restaurant waiting four hours for one
dish
this is what happens at the restaurant
when a pork belly stir-fry orange comes
in
we take out the free portion we separate
the bean curd with the pork belly
while it's still full we're going to add
a fermented black beans this is where
most of the flavor comes from
some garlic we got some fresh milk
chilies
saute that a little bit our bean curd is
stuffed
this is a chinese celery it gives the
dish a nice extra crunch
[Music]
got a little cornstarch for all the
sauce to stick to the protein and then
curd all right this is it this is the
hakka stir-fry
with the pork belly bean curd and
chinese celery
quality control always an excuse
so this is our stir-fried pork belly now
let me show you how we do our braised
pork belly
it's been three hours and so this pork
belly braise is done
so the texture is getting a lot thicker
because of all the gelatin that's kind
of
thickening up the sauce and the color is
becoming
much more of a dark coffee color because
of the soy sauce and sugar that all kind
of is emulsifying together with the
water
so one of the dishes that we use the
braised pork belly for
is our pork belly bud so we got
these bowel buns they are from a local
bakery here in new york
nice and petite but very soft gonna oil
the griddle a little bit
here we have water so it's important to
toast your buns because
of the texture contrast you get a nice
crispy bottom but the top is nice and
filler
nice pork belly super tender and crazy
it's a great base for the flavor funky
pickled mustard green
provides a nice acidity and funkiness
that balances out the fattiness of the
pork
peanut powder provides sweetness and
this is our
pork belly bun with our braised pork
belly base pickle mustard green
peanut powder and cilantro
[Music]
so the last dish we use our pork belly
for is our number one best seller
it's the raised portfolio of rice aka
the low bobbin
it's always very important to fluff your
rice just so that each grain will get
even coating for sauce push it down the
center so
the sauce doesn't drizzle on the edges
now we're gonna scoop the pork belly
sauce
nice ladle here plate it a little bit
of our pickled mustard green again this
is a very classic pairing
some cilantro on the side we have the
soft oil chicken egg it's been
marinating in soy sauce for a while
so this is how we prepare our pork belly
rice with our pork belly base
pickle mustard greens cilantro and our
soft boiled egg it's a very comforting
delicious luscious yet balanced dish
quality control part three
i mean it's our best seller for a reason
pork belly is a great ingredient so
versatile you can cook it at home ahead
of time you can braise it
stir fry it grill it raw marinated and
it yields great results
today i showed you guys how i prep 200
pounds of pork belly in my restaurant
now i have a dinner rush to tend to so
i'll see you guys later
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you